l'ultima volta che ho fatto
un'esperienza con uno chef non è andata
benissimo la spezia
quando poi già adesso napoletano
supporto anche come mai questa per
questo tra l'altro è un vino molto
particolare perché oggi alfonso mi
insegnerà a cucinare cosa che non è mai
tutti state aspettando video di cucina
quando aperto il canale lo so anche mia
madre sono contento mamma finalmente è
arrivato a questo punto del mio della
mia carriera bene quindi dobbiamo
rendere giustizia che cosa è questo
comunque ragazze allora quali ricette 6
fare che conosco sono quelle di the sims
quali i quali ricette che si misura
la torta al cioccolato cacao ok
fattibilissimo per fare la torta al
cioccolato quella di desing su quella
americana dobbiamo usare pochi
ingredienti non tantissimi ma buoni
allora che una cosa iniziamo col nullo
col burro sì ma mi sembra un po troppo
tutto sto puro non me lo troviamo la net
aria e il burro si fa questo e lo
zucchero cielo di mettere dentro vai vai
vai vai cosa dobbiamo aggiungere le uova
le uova di campagna dei vari campagna
perché l'abbiamo presa e ovviamente in
campagna le rompono trentenne napoletano
non bisogna è meglio che tutta la cosa
fa al
completo io sono interessato cosa mai
vista che può apparire el'altra non si
può dire inside line e adesso che
dobbiamo fare spiace che non si vede
quando c'è dentro le che costa di stampa
diventa roba adesso chiudiamo e tiriamo
mai vedi questa roba adesso che cosa ti
dobbiamo aggiungere alla destra ci
aggiungiamo di tutta questa roba che
stiamo vedendo allora io indico magica
di suspense
no non c'è proposte di tutta la ricetta
del latte non c'è proprio tutto
questa farina brava marina la quale
aspetta prima di metterlo all'interno
questo lo stai facciata già perché per
evitare di fare ok ma che cosa ci
mettiamo nella farina
valanzano si è facile ma parmigiano
pizzico di sale e un pizzico i've some
truth che ne sono magari a vita nato già
ma che tornato quello bravo e questo è
tutto presepi carbonato barca infatti
pensavo di aver messo la farina nella
farina e dobbiamo imburrare le griglie e
io so che tu sei bravissima segnalato
però non so più imburrato tempo un
allora io so che tu se proprio dovete
chiamare che diciamo bravo
licenza
teschi può mai così bravo bravo bravo
continua così ha aggiunto alla tempia
germogli a my lai così tornata così io
faccio così
non va ok una volta fatto questo non
prenderei perché adesso dobbiamo passare
il cacao all'interno si
ok ma questa che si è fatto un ragazzo
ha sbagliato e spero ora di
bellissimo parma viene ci siamo vuoi la
mano mi grazie perché pesa più di questa
pentola adesso andiamo a mettere in puri
così si fanno ora visto che io non ho
ancora problemi di vista e mi sembra che
le torte se le guardie bene siano due
diventerà uno prendiamo con delicatezza
perfetto se il numero uno e mento bello
bellissimo forma va beh ok mettiamo
questa la coperchio nano piano
perfetto
ok tanto alle torte americane
soprattutto questo acquisì nella parte
esterna non deve essere perfetta è
proprio fatta così ok va bene questa
piacere l'amore raramente perché quando
ma devi mangiare voleva mettere sopra
this is the best cake in the world the
chocolate mirtillo biscotto saca porsche
che
la torta è finita ci abbiamo messo video
tagliato molto poco video non tagliato
due ore ma ti faccio vedere che non
l'avrei fatta io sì
io l'avrei fatto così ed è molto più
facile e allora facciamo vedere
d'alfonso come si cucina una roba allora
innanzitutto la prima cosa che si deve
fare è andare andare al frigo la prima
cosa da wright frigor ad equi cucina
dove la roba dove stavano eccola qua un
uovo 1 buona ciocco barca lo sciroppo al
ciocco marca che sa capaci ciocco bacca
e poi farina e zucchero a tutte e due o
uno l'altro non si chiama certo non si
trova due le prove per market anzi ce le
coltiviamo è il pollaio eccolo eccolo
acquista i folli acquisti folli tutti
quanti fuori posto fra apple ai 1300
euro dei polli normale ho acquistato di
polli e adesso forse posso mangiare
mangime va bene facciamo il mangime
parole ciocco bachelet e volete voi
guarda a vista per gli impeti dati
prodotti agricoli abnormi va va bene me
lo faresti un provino che mi serve uno
solo raccoglie le uova non le hanno
fatte però attenzione alle 6 del mattino
stanno le uova nel frattempo beppe
vediamo se riusciamo a mettere choco
marche
allora ragazzi siccome questa è la nuova
mappa di herford o bello è che pronuncia
pazzesca magari cesta prodotti chilowat
eccolo qua veli che vendono roba mediche
la vende la choco bacca ciocco park ne
prendo anche due tanto ciò li sordi mi
servirebbe ora farina o lo zucchero
questa la facciamo marino tra un po una
torta salata e reway ho comprato tutta
la roba è adesso il momento sono le tre
ma andiamo a dormire perché almeno alle
6 del mattino teoricamente dovrebbe
arrivare l'uovo si sta fissando a sotto
stop christian mi dispiace non passando
dall arrivo a non essere il mattino solo
passatempo file è andato a dormire per
questo jean jetlag mancano ancora sei
ore resisti e dormi resisti e dormi non
ti pisciare addosso dormi è andato
dall'altra parte a sole sei perpetua
alzare si è dormito tipo due giorni però
fa niente e volevo dire se ce l'ho letto
raccoglie nuova attenzione attenzione
attenzione in avanti si sa veramente
cosa si mangerebbe tutto qualsiasi cosa
prendi l'uovo prendilo dai veloci escono
maggi ha preso lei di loro madonna posso
ragazzi addirittura piantarle le ciocco
batte vorrei che lo facessi quando
smetti ti fa il bagno che ha smesso
voglio vedere attivino come togliti
paolo scusami che sto facendo una roba
importante va bene c'è sempre un pollo
de mezzo gallina gallina o che ha posto
acquisita l'abilità di giochi comunque a
parte anna piani folli
che secondo non è troppo felice cioè
igiene alta felicità bassa fame estrema
sembro io e la mia vita è il momento o
oggi facciamo la torta al cioccolato un
uovo facciamo che al volo ma wire
modifiche come faccio io faccio il
11 era un lo abbiamo esagerato o farina
o zucchero tutto
ciò comacchio sciroppo di cioccolato
certo è un caso quindi il timone non è
parca medici du palais che quello non
appena glielo ha fatto barca quale la
jacob h cioè allora aveva fatto casini
basta né ciocco bakker tutti semplici
qua molto più fasce guarda
ecco adesso lui tirati fuori guardavi
periodo vedi come se la stessa camicia
che l'ho fatto apposta bene
questo dice l'attuale la stessa cosa
domanda un po velocizzato perché almeno
l'olio la missione del pd mi ha messo
nella lazio sbagliato ha sbagliato fatto
il casinò però ha la metti nel forno
tutto fuori
va bene poi riescono nella parità eccola
la media porta tanti qui lo la lo assumo
suggeritore di bossi ha messo tutto
tengono tutto a posto ragazzi per
attricette seguiteci
[Musica]